[Music]
[Applause]
hi guys we are here at force Friday -
they're gonna launch all the new Star
Wars products tonight and so many fans
have come out to get all this new stuff
you can just feel the excitement in the
air
it's like comic-con for toys I can't
wait
I love fan events because everybody's
energy is always so up there you know
everyone's so excited to see all the new
Star Wars merch maybe we can only see
part of the line from here you're here
for force Friday I'm here for first
Friday
I don't normally hang out at targets at
midnight yeah man is it crowded people
have been here for hours look at all
these nope just don't you don't actually
have to show them look at all these
people whoa oh they go on for miles
when I say force you say Friday force
ride a horse
Friday someone you keep will chain it
along yeah how long have you been here
five six hours
oh no not nearly actually only been here
like 30 minutes that's not very exciting
can you just say you've been here for
eight hours yeah I've been here for
about eight hours that's such a long
time there was a lot more people at Toys
R Us like people in costumes like people
in costumes in costumes with lightsabers
and everything yeah there's like
cosplayers and lightsaber duels with you
were dueling yeah and there's a little
puppy dress-up as Chewbacca and he's so
cute it sounds lame I'm so glad I came
here yeah it's gonna be so much fun yeah
good great
don't worry so what are you gonna get
since you're gonna be one of the first
ones in oh I kind of want that five foot
pork I don't know what the chances are
of getting that thing there's a five
foot pork yeah you can win it here I
don't think you can buy it though
if you didn't want it would you consider
giving it to me if you like if they
handed it to you and you were like oh
now that I'm looking at it up close I
don't like it that much I'll give you
the eBay link any particular figures
like clear glitter smoke or snap Wexley
with new TIE fighter x-wing battle
playset we're gonna go
the spears heroes not if I get there
first this is a small spoiler I did hear
that BB 90 is gonna murder Luke
Skywalker oh yeah that's nothing
it happens at like 45 minutes into the
film so okay it's not like the big
movies barely act - yeah are you gonna
get the Luke's funeral barge playset
that comes with Rey wearing her new
turned to the dark side
outfit she's wearing like a thing that
says in Arabic I'm evil now yeah I'm
also excited to pick up a Lord and
Miller homeless action figure nice comes
with a box and a letter of resignation
are they gonna have the new guards and
the Praetorian Elite Guard squadron yes
that I hope so I love getting a toy of
something that looks like somebody 3d
printed it at home good luck today at
force Friday in my experience there's no
such thing as luck well how about this
may the force Friday be with you ah May
the first Friday BB 90 with you my god
it's my show Jesus
oh man we're gonna go get some Star Wars
stuff I'm gonna get everything
[Music]
I got a point and I got a BB tiny
they have a little pork and it does
something look at that he's even cuter
than bb-8 who I used to love oh my new
best friend
press and shake : really makes these
noises when you shake him
did I have any like spoilers on these
action figures they decided not to
include Finn throwing some shade and
leaving Finn out of the group set this
time I'm gonna get this gen or so
pillowcase that has a picture of jyn
erso and it says hope just like jyn erso
does so we have this um what is this
it's one of those Hasbro playmates ones
you can see Luke with his gigantic metal
hand raised got her lightsaber Captain
phasma has a giant like shoulder cannon
Rose Tico I think he's holding dynamite
and look r2d2 straight-up has jetpacks
mounted to him to fly with so people are
passing this one by I think this might
be the most spoiler if ik thing that I
have found at force Friday - they have a
Rey PEZ dispenser this is probably the
worst toy I have ever seen actually no
this is the worst toy I've ever seen it
doesn't even look like it's anything hey
kids step right up
get your praetorian guard from this
plush we learned that in the new film
Chewie is showing his age he's
definitely seen better days and he looks
like he's been eaten by a dog I think in
the last Jedi the stormtroopers are all
gonna be riding these guys and they're
gonna look good doing it this isn't like
a spoiler but I love a good blade
builder you can make all these crazy
ugly combinations of lightsabers and
this one's yellow maybe ray will have a
yellow lightsaber and then everyone will
be even more convinced that she's
exactly like vast Allah Shan just helped
everyone's conspiracy theory with that
maybe her lightsaber will look like this
we do know she's good at fighting with
the staff and that is similar so these
have been picked clean they still have
Rey who I guess the fans don't like not
judging or anything she is the main
character
we have a captain phasma Oh another girl
character I'm not saying it's kylo Ren
and it looks like he's just stuck in one
pose i this would be weird to play with
like hello i'm carl redden i'm gonna
getcha
maybe he makes this pose a lot in the
new movie we haven't seen it rose Tico
the new character Luke Skywalker's love
interest this handsome devil supreme
leader snoke I love that apparently he's
just rocking a gold robe for this whole
film I think it's a great look Chewbacca
has a tiny pork in his hand he's gonna
shove it right in his mouth Young says
Chewbacca here we have our new Spiro
products they have BB 90 and the target
people were just telling me that this
plays evil sinister music when it rolls
around I love him oh my god the biggest
pork I've ever seen him probably will
ever see until my dying day our friend
won the giant pork he won it I'm happy
for him and I don't resent him okay well
the poor adoptions are over everybody's
starting to go home and all they have
left are these giant Praetorian guards
why do they have so many of these why
didn't these sellout I don't understand
pretty successful force Friday got a lot
of good stuff
I'm surprised cuz there were so many
people here it was very competitive but
I did it that's how you know I'm the
biggest fan
because I like new characters like
Borges time to go home
[Music]
you